У цьому розділі ми надамо основу
для розуміння комп'ютерних середовищ,
яка підходить як для твого ноутбука,
так і для суперкомп'ютерів.
Після цього розділу
ти зрозумієш базові концепції комп'ютерних ресурсів
та як вони пов'язані між собою.
Отже, що таке комп'ютерні ресурси? Простіше кажучи,
це компоненти, що складають комп'ютерну систему.
Є CPU — центральний процесор,
який виконує більшість інструкцій; є пам'ять,
або RAM, що тимчасово зберігає дані
та інструкції програм.
А ще є GPU — графічні процесори,
що призначені для рендерингу графіки,
але також використовуються для задач загального обчислення,
що вимагають масового паралельного опрацювання, —
наприклад наукових симуляцій, аналітики або машинного навчання.
Ці ресурси працюють разом для виконання програм,
і кожен має власні одиниці вимірювання.
Наприклад, ресурси CPU вимірюються в ядрах
та тактовій частоті, а пам'ять — у байтах:
гіга-, мега- та терабайтах.
Для кожної з наших задач
нам знадобиться певний набір ресурсів
для їхнього виконання.
Дуже важливо враховувати ресурси, потрібні для запуску програм,
ефективне розміщення їхніх компонентів,
а також пропускну здатність інфраструктури, що їх з'єднує —
все це суттєво
впливає на загальну продуктивність.
Наприклад, GPU може швидше обрахувати певні частини
програми, але якщо завантаження даних у пам'ять GPU
займає більше часу, ніж сам розрахунок,
можливо, ефективніше буде використати CPU.
Поговоримо тепер про масштабування класичних ресурсів.
Є два підходи: вертикальне масштабування
та горизонтальне. Вертикальне масштабування — це збільшення
потужності одного ресурсу,
наприклад встановлення потужнішого CPU або більшого обсягу пам'яті
в одному фізичному вузлі,
де вузол — це одиниця обчислювального кластера, що об'єднує декілька
ресурсів. Горизонтальне масштабування
передбачає додавання нових ресурсів,
наприклад кількох CPU або GPU,
що спільно працюють на одному або кількох вузлах.
Обидва підходи мають свої переваги
та недоліки, і вибір залежить від конкретного
сценарію та вимог. Розглянемо новий тип ресурсів —
квантові. Квантові ресурси обробляють квантову інформацію
за допомогою квантового процесорного пристрою, або QPU. QPU —
це вся система, відповідальна
за приймання виконуваного квантового набору інструкцій,
або quantum circuit, і повернення
точного результату. Це означає,
що QPU включає один або кілька квантових чипів,
наприклад квантовий процесор IBM Heron,
а також багато додаткових компонентів
у холодильнику розведення,
що охолоджує квантовий чип, —
як-от квантовий підсилювач, керуюча електроніка
та класичний комп'ютер, потрібний
для таких завдань, як зберігання інструкцій
і форм сигналів у пам'яті, накопичення результатів
та майбутнє декодування при корекції помилок.
Загалом квантові ресурси вимірюються
за якістю: за шкалою Layer Fidelity,
кількістю qubit,
а також швидкістю — кількістю операцій circuit layer
на секунду, або CLOPS. Сьогодні ми розглядаємо квантовий чип
як одиницю вимірювання, подібно до того, як системи управління ресурсами
розглядають GPU не за кількістю ядер,
а як цілісну одиницю. А що з масштабуванням?
Як і з класичними ресурсами, масштабування квантових ресурсів
також поділяється на вертикальне
та горизонтальне. Вертикальне масштабування
— це збільшення кількості qubit на чиплет
або на чип.
Горизонтальне масштабування — це з'єднання чипів
за допомогою з'єднувачів або класичних інтерконектів.
Тепер, коли з визначеннями розібралися,
поговоримо про управління ресурсами.
Управління ресурсами в комп'ютерній інфраструктурі —
це процес планування,
розподілу та контролю обчислювальних ресурсів,
таких як CPU, пам'ять, сховище
та мережева пропускна здатність, — для забезпечення ефективного
та результативного їх використання.
Управління ресурсами можна уявити
як багатовимірний тетріс, де блоки —
це вимоги твого завдання,
а кожен вимір — одиниця певного ресурсу. Загальна задача —
розмістити ці блоки-завдання у кубі
з усіх доступних ресурсів. Управління ресурсами —
надзвичайно складне завдання, і різні обчислювальні центри застосовують
різні підходи до налаштування своєї інфраструктури
відповідно до потреб своїх користувачів.
Щоб застосувати щойно вивчені концепції, ми будемо використовувати
Slurm. Slurm — це програмне забезпечення з відкритим кодом
для управління ресурсами.
Для демонстрації я
розгорнув локальне середовище з трьома віртуальними вузлами.
Отримати інформацію про ці обчислювальні вузли
можна за допомогою команди scontrol.
Маємо два розділи, або групи вузлів:
normal та quantum. Розділ normal містить вузли
з доступом лише до класичних ресурсів,
а розділ quantum — до квантових ресурсів.
Почнемо з простого
класичного прикладу "Hello, World!" у Slurm.
Спочатку потрібна сама програма hello world.
Ось наша програма — вона просто виводить "Hello,
World!".
Тепер потрібно повідомити менеджеру ресурсів,
які ресурси потрібні для запуску цієї програми.
Як ми вже обговорювали, Slurm дозволяє вказати
всі метадані для завдання через
скрипт оболонки (shell script)
зі спеціальними анотаціями Slurm.
Ці анотації дають змогу вказати вимоги до ресурсів,
параметри планування та інше.
Можна переглянути наш скрипт подачі завдань —
тут є вказівка розділу,
скільки вузлів потрібно, скільки задач на вузол
буде запущено, скільки CPU на задачу використовуватиметься
та який скрипт буде виконуватися.
Це і є наша програма hello world.
Щоб поставити завдання на виконання, достатньо запустити
одну команду — sbatch —
передавши наш скрипт як аргумент.
Можна перевірити чергу виконання
і побачити, що програма hello world запущена
на розділі normal, вузлі node-c1.
Коли завдання завершується, можна перевірити результати,
переглянувши файл виводу.
Ось і все.
Нас також цікавить використання квантових ресурсів,
тому створімо просту програму "Hello, Qiskit!".
Ось наша програма Qiskit, яка містить усі
необхідні кроки: створення circuit,
оптимізацію, виконання та постобробку.
Тут зібрані всі програмні концепції, про які ми говорили:
quantum circuit, transpiler
та примітиви Qiskit.
Тепер потрібно створити скрипт подачі завдань,
як і раніше, але тут ми вказуємо
вимоги до квантових ресурсів.
Оскільки ресурси вказано,
і розділ кластера визначено,
система знає, які квантові ресурси доступні.
Примітиви Qiskit використовуватимуть
виділені ресурси для виконання квантових обчислень.
Тепер запустимо нашу програму.
Коли завдання виконається, перевіримо результати.
Ось наше очікуване значення.
Це все про управління ресурсами.
У наступному розділі ми поговоримо
про моделі програмування.